let's kick things off with basketball
this one is for all the march madness
fans that will be watching from home
this weekend
although watch parties and celebrations
look different this year
one local company i love this idea is
making sure you at least have
a cardboard version of your family and
friends
here's rocky with screaming images
we're getting ready for march madness
this weekend i'm here with my golden
knights fans obviously they're not ready
for basketball but
you can be if you call screaming images
they can cut they can do a life-size
cutout of you and your friends
and you can bring the madness to your
living room how do we do that james
all you got to do is go to the website
www.screamingimages.net
click on the fan cutout link and it's
going to give you three easy steps it's
going to tell you how to take your photo
what you need to have in the background
and uh and then it's going to direct you
to upload your photo
that easy that's easy so how does it
work i see something coming out of the
printer right now how do you guys do
this
well uh this is obviously not a cutout
but on the cutouts we
we first we design a contour line around
the shape
and then when it prints it out it prints
some black dots around the edge of it
and when we take it to the cnc router
the cnc router reads the dots and that's
how it knows what pattern
to take and apply to that and what about
what about size-wise can we get
life-size can we get
more we can obviously mix it up right
unless you're unless you're over eight
feet tall we can get life-size
all right well i see a couple you know
big-time celebrities this is what i love
about this operation here we've got some
really famous cutouts
we've got darren waller of the raiders
we've got floyd mayweather and we've got
rocky theists of las vegas now i'm just
saying this is like a huge deal
this is so cool i get to take this home
this is the most famous person i've ever
had in my shop
oh wow and it's it's seriously life-size
i'm six foot one
this is amazing so you guys deliver this
too yeah we can deliver it uh
full delivery services no charge wow and
tell us about the charity
um donations as well yeah so everybody
that everybody that uh that goes to the
fan cutout link and
and uploaded that way we donate 100 to
charities
boys and girls club animal shelter stuff
like that that is amazing james thank
you so much i love screaming images i
always want to stay here and play all
day
i'll send it back to you that is so cool
hers looked really good yeah that's
awesome i feel like that would be a
great gift
all right thank